القوة الضاربة لصدام
، أكبر مشروع أقيم في العراق
، مشروع أرعب إسرائيل
وأخاف الجارة إيران
مشروع كافح صدام ليبنيه
واجه شتى أنواع الضغوطات والتهديدات
في سبيل إقامة مشروعه
، أعلنت إسرائيل الحرب على العراق بسببه
، ياترى لماذا؟ ومالذي أخاف الدول الكبرى
وعلى رأسها إسرائيل من مشروع صدام؟
(المفاعل النووي العراقي)،
،
سمي بالأخوين تموز، و مفاعل تموز أو مفاعل أوزيراك
تم إنشاء المفاعل باتفاق
بين رئيس جمهورية فرنسا وبين صدام حسين
عندما كان هذا الأخير نائب للرئيس العراقي
أصبحت العراق عضوا في الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية
عام ١٩٥٩ وحتى العام ١٩٧٢
حين قررت العراق الحصول على محطة كهرو نووية
من فرنسا بسعة ٥١٥ميجاوات وظل الطلب
حتى عام ١٩٧٤
حين قوبل الطلب بالرفض القطعي لأسباب كثيرة
أهمها عدم السماح للشرق الأوسط بامتلاك المفاعل
أو المحطات النووية،
قبل ذلك كان العراق قد حاول الحصول على محطة نووية
بالتعاون مع كندا، لكن هذا الطلب  قوبل بالرفض أيضا
في عام ١٩٧٤
، لذا اتجهت العراق للخيار الأخير  عام ١٩٧٥
وهو نيوكليبراس البرازيلية بسعة ٩٨٠ ميجاوات
لكن الخبرة الضعيفة لنيوكليبراس وتخصصها داخليا فقط
دون تجربة خارجية أفشل محاولة العراق
ولم تكتمل العملية،
(وهاهو المفاعل)
بعد مساع حثيثة لصدام حسين
ليستطيع امتلاك مفاعل نووي وفي بداية العام ١٩٧٥
وافقت الرئاسة الفرنسية على بناء مفاعلين نوويين في العراق
،  الأول(أوزيرايس) ويدعى تموز١
بسعة ٤٠ ميجاوات قابل للتطوير إلى ٧٠ ميجاوات،
أما الثاني(ISIS) ويدعى تموز٢، فكان مفاعل تدريبي
بسعة ٦٠٠ كيلوات،  وجاءت الموافقة
بعد زيارة الرئيس الفرنسي جاك شيراك لبغداد
خلال عام ١٩٧٥ تلتها زيارة لصدام حسين  لباريس
عندها وقع صدام مع هيئة الطاقة الذرية والبديلة
في مدينة ساكليه
، وبعدها بيوم واحد تم إضفاء الرسمية على الاتفاقية
بتوقيع العراق ملحق مع الوكالة االدولية للطاقة الذرية،
(بداية المناوشات)
عند بداية إنشاء المفاعلين حاول أفراد من الموساد الإسرائيلي
القيام بعمليات تخريبية لمنع الإنشاء
لكن ذلك لم يؤدي إلا لتأخير الإنشاء سوى لعام واحد
تلى ذلك عملية اغتيال لعالمين نوويين في مشروع المفاعل
وبطرق مختلفة، لكن الخطة فشلت وتم إنشاء المفاعل
وفي نفس أسبوع توقيع المفاعل النووي كانت إيران
قد وقعت مع أمريكا على صفقة
شراء طائرات إف ١٦،
لكن الصفقة فشلت بعد نجاح الثورة الإسلامية هناك،
وقامت إسرائيل بشراء الصفقة
وأرسلت ثمان من هذه الطائرات
لقصف المفاعل النووي في العراق
وتم إطلاق ١٢ صاروخا..
صاروخان منهم فقط من أصابا الهدف
شهرين فقط احتاجتهما فرنسا فقط لترمم الخراب
في المفاعل وقليل من المال أضافته العراق للتكلفة الإجمالية،
(عملية أوبرا)
بعد عدم نجاح الضربة الأولى
، قررت إسرائيل ضرب المفاعل بنفسها،
وجهزت ٨ طائرات تحمل كل طائرة صاروخين
يحوي كل صاروخ على
٧أطنان من الTNTالمتفجرة،
كما أضافت سرب من طائرات إف ١٥
للمراقبة والحماية،
وكانت الخطة بضرب موقعين مختلفين
أحدهما المفاعل والثاني موقع آخر بعيد عنه
لتشتيت الرادارت العراقية،
وكان اختيار وقت القصف موفقا جدا باختيار
وقت تناول موظفي منظومة الدفاع الجوية العراقية للعشاء،
وإضاف للضربة الأولى في مكان آخر لضمان العملية،
عندها أطلقت الطائرات صواريخها وقصفت المفاعل
ولم يدرِ القائمون عليه بالعملية إلا وقد فات الأوان
، وتمّ تدمير مبنى المفاعلين بالكامل مع المختبر الحار
وغرف السيطرة والمختبر الذرّي والمختبر الإيطالي والمعهد النووي،،
أصابت هذه الضربة الإسرائيلية العراقيين في مقتل
في الوقت الذي انشغل صدام بغزو الكويت
وحرب الخليج والمعارك مع أمريكا
لم يستطع حينها أعادة بناء المفاعل
وما زاد الطين بلة هو الحصار الذي أطبقته أمريكا
والتحالف على العراق فانشغل صدام حينها بالمحافظة
على دولته، وكُتبت النهاية لمفاعل كان ليرد
ولو قليلا من قوة واعتبار العرب
فمن سيجرؤ حاليا
على امتلاك مفاعل نووي في
الشرق الأوسط بأكمله؟...